irrésistible elles l'ont fait une année
en or championne d'europe cocorico mais
une des journaux en ce sens les joueuses
françaises
l'arrière droite alexandra lacrabère qui
joue actuellement à fleury-les-aubrais
assurent les derniers buts tricolores 24
à 21
la russie bête noire de la france est
tombée hier soir dans l'équipe de
handball
on dénombre aussi deux joueuses de la
région l'actuel nantaise originaire dany
pauleta faux pas et la drouaise siraba
dembélé suis vraiment heureuse et fière
franchement ce qu'on a accompli c'est
énorme s'est pas hissé pas facile de
rester
voilà de faire 2 ou hindous un doublé
deux années consécutives c'est c'est
super franchement c'est une belle perf
suis désolé ce peut-être qu'on va penser
que je manque un peu d'humilité mais
j'ai envie de savourer ce moment et
voilà de reconnaître que voilà ce qu'on
a fait ces nombres tout simplement un
moment d'émotion une victoire
inoubliable pour leur entraîneur olivier
krumbholz le faiseur de rennes est aussi
un joli cadeau pour les 18 ans de
pauleta faux pas ce week-end en rêvant
peut-être d'un autre succès à tokyo en
[Applaudissements]